hi good morning might not be morning
where you are so how do you feel today
way home very individual only and yet
when I ask people that question on a
seminar do you feel that you're an
individual I would think I do percent
put the hands up and the other 20%
perhaps didn't want to put their hand up
but still feel individual and yet
there's many things that cost I will
make us all all alike it doesn't matter
what nationality you are where you come
from in the world we will dissolver the
same things really health happiness
enough money to survive happiness in our
family you know well-being for those
around us caring for others well then
you get other people who are very
selfish and then you think of themselves
nothing else matters as long as they
survive what makes an Aikido car that's
a person that studies like you don't
different than anyone else I can only
talk about myself and some of it might
apply to you so I'm hoping it does works
you wouldn't be watching or listening to
me the individuality of why I've been
doing like you know for 47 years it's
because of well a multi-million pound
business of what our family lived a very
busy life lots of hobbies yeah I had
done many things in business and was
known in the local newspapers
entrepreneur and some people would say
by now oh he's talking about my I I me
me me
and yes fact I am and perhaps I'm
talking about us me you even with all
the things we do the one thing that once
told in Aikido after 47 years is for
several things but the one main thing is
is one thing I cannot master each time I
feel that I'm getting closer to
understanding all I need to understand
at first it used to come with a with the
award of another grade another cue belt
another comment bellow help me then they
Ultima is black belt if you can get the
black belt you've arrived just to find
out that the day after you've got the
black belt you're really happy be on the
same person the same person who woke up
this morning did you wake up happy did
you wake up sad do you know why he woke
up happy or sad does it really matter
you're not going to change it however
you woke up we can actually change it
because you can think in your mind or
even say out loud today I choose not to
go there of course you're not going to
more normal only say that if you're
feeling happy I who's not going to
choose to want to be happy get a good
technique on the mat have a good
training have a good partner that's
that's a happy time
I've been to so many different countries
training with salary definition a letís
and afterwards we talk and perhaps as a
language problem the lucky thing being
English is the world speaks English nor
most of it Ania
so I've had most conversations but when
it comes down to the conversations we
really all become the cyan't
artists all as I want when it comes to
Aikido there's no magic button that
makes us any different but it is a
passion and I believe that Aikido is a
great art for perfectionists because it
will drive effects this mad
we can't master you see I'm not here to
put you off I'm actually here to sell
you the product I want the world to be
doing a like you know it doesn't matter
what style I was talking of early on the
other film there is so many styles I
couldn't even put a figure on it I read
once there were 17 different stars like
you don't well each time there's a
teacher come from a student come from a
teacher the style will change the
problem is the techniques should never
change
I've given up drinking about 11 years
ago never alcohol my favorite drink as
boring as it sounds is a cup of tea I'm
very fussy it's a mug above in China mug
and I really enjoy my tea in it we all
have something that we treasure and like
that's what the word treasure is a
little bit over the top for mug but we
do tend to find things that we like a
special present a special gift what
makes us different what makes us special
well we're special because we are self
we are we are the person that arrived on
this earth and we sometimes wonder who
we are that's another question I get you
know another hobby that I do another
field that I do
many people come up to me after I do
some small stage performances in psychic
work and people say to me what is my
purpose in life Oh a sentence II what
was skip we call morihei ueshiba the
founder of but I suppose we can say the
founder of aikido really he he took from
so many different arts and you can read
about his life you you don't need me to
go all about in tell you about it you
can read it but the pieces I do tell you
they just snippets of wife picked up
more I found interesting but he if you
like took the good bits that he
considered
from the martial arts and made a series
of techniques and we call it a syllabus
nail that we followed but the human body
can only do so many things it does
matter what are you choose you can only
perform so many things with your body
now the mind is expensive and it can be
limitless but it depends how deep you go
into looking at your mind the mind is a
mirror and sometimes we don't like
looking in the mirror in case we see the
person we're not happy with myself so Oh
sensei it means great teacher great
master but was he such a great master
those that followed him said they didn't
understand him they didn't understand
the words he they spoke about know a
great teacher would look at their
students and they would help the
students to understand what they're
trying to teach in the old days it was
osho and you must copy the Western world
I'm afraid doesn't have that ability it
asks questions why should I do this what
will happen if I do this so we're not
giving the mind time to be empty or to
discover what the my nose so the Western
world is full of questions and answers
the eastern world is you shall old copy
so perhaps if we could go and have a
piece of both that would be the best way
of going about it
some of the look and copy while on the
mat leaving an empty mind then after you
finished training in your home and time
or with your friends even talk and
discuss what you think but my advice is
don't take it within the mask if you
keep criticizing every move or trying to
change every move you're not copying
you've seen and now you're trying to
adjust these films are not designed to
go in any particular order so up to you
to dip in and they'll see what you like
seeing where you don't like switch ON
switch off and I've already from yes
that I and I made my first film had 10
suggestions of what to talk about so if
I live long enough and the suggestions
keep coming in we'll have many many
things to discuss so leave your comments
below and I'll pick up as many as I can
and we'll go through them when next
session we'll be talking about Keisha
Myrna Curitiba who was our census son
who lived in Tokyo and we're gonna cover
up many many aspects
I don't you have a good day